il est 12h30 ce mercredi elia 18 ans
quitte les locaux de l'externat
médicalisé de trappes pour entrer chez
elle à montigny la jeune fille est
atteinte de trisomie 21
autonome et liam a emprunté deux lignes
de bus différentes
une passagère comme les autres c'est
d'ailleurs comme les autres que la élevé
laurence sa maman et il ya on a je
tenais à la fois ask réel et le maximum
de confort et sa vie la plus semblable
de celle des autres jeunes de son âge
donc on a vraiment beaucoup
invitée d'enfants est à la fois lui
apprendre voilà à nous quitter donc très
jeune elle a été en coller une vacance
donc qu'on essayait de ne pas l'enfermer
dans le handicap mais l'ouvrir au monde
aussi bien pour elle mais aussi pour les
autres il ya un téléphone portable
dispose d'une boîte mail avec laquelle
elle peut discuter avec ses copines et
dans sa chambre comme toutes les
adolescentes
il ya des posters de ses chanteurs
préférés c'est alan à hannah montana ah
oui et elle aussi le riz et 6 cylindres
selena gomez est en hausse et jennifer
lopez
il ya aime particulièrement le
maquillage clyro ce soir est ce notre
journaliste est l'objet de toutes ses
attentions
elia est aussi très coquette regard à
l'organique au leur et cela ce sera le
rose cela est réel et les verts et c'est
pour ton amoureux ton amoureux oui c'est
ça paye ça peut être est il le sait oui
la jeune fille a aussi posé récemment
pour une photographe mélanie garnier
les clichés ont été présentés au
conservatoire des arts de montigny il ya
est très très épanouie sans inhibition
une grande joie de vivre
une facilité de contact qui est quand
même en très agréable pour les gens donc
à regarde toujours très très positif ce
qui fait que l ai vite acceptée par par
les jeunes et par les adultes
le cirque le théâtre elia multiplie les
activités
il est 18 heures la jeune fille rejoint
son cours de danse africaine
une discipline qu'elle pratique depuis
l'âge de 6 ans toujours au milieu des
autres
et bien c'est parti
des enfants je veux dire bonheur parce
que du coup par rapport à son handicap
elle s'en fiche un peu de tout le monde
moi au niveau pédagogique samassa a été
formateur voilà pour la canaliser
trouver les outils qui allait permettre
de faire en sorte qu'elle se concentre
jusqu'à la fin du cours du coup je le
vois plus du tout en phase on handicap
malgré l'éducation qui lui a été
prodigué laurence sa maman n'est pas
naïve elle mesure les difficultés qu'il
reste à parcourir pour une intégration
notamment professionnelles les préjugés
que les gens pu avoir à son égard c'est
jamais face à elle parce qu'un préjugé
c'est quand on ne connaît pas donc on
n'a pas eu à faire enfin elle appelle à
faire directement à à ce type de projet
dans notre parcours on est souvent voilà
confronté à des gens qui ne connaissent
pas et quand on ne connaît pas on a peur
la trisomie 21 est la première
déficience intellectuelle d'origine
génétique
une conception sur 700 est concerné
aujourd'hui il existe un diagnostic
prénatal dans 96% des cales des parents
décident d'un avortement médical pour
les autres le regard est parfois lourd à
porter d'où cette deuxième journée
internationale de sensibilisation et
d'information
elle a lieu le 21 mars